[MUSIC PLAYING]
IAN LAKE: So when the
Android framework goes
to start your application from
the Launcher icon, or an app
shortcut, or what you see when
you're doing Multi-Window,
those are all activities, right?
So they really are, kind of, the
entry point into your app's UI.
When the user goes
to launch your app,
they're launching an activity.
What you actually want if you
want to build the layering
you actually need.
So in this case, we can
have multiple things,
multiple destinations
within an activity,
and share information across
each of these destinations
by using the activity scope as
an actual useful element now.
So for example, you could have
a shared view element or view
model that both
destinations talk to.
So one destination
could put data in.
And the other one could
observe changes to that data.
You don't need to work
at the application scope
level for this to work.
When we're thinking
about this, like if we're
moving from this activity world
to a destination and world--
we really want to make that
world as easy as possible.
Otherwise, why would we move?
And we focused on two things.
One was that global UI thing.
Like, how can we
make that are easy?
It's something that every app
has the same kind of patterns
and we really don't want
that to be something that
takes a lot of effort to do.
Also, the navigating
between destinations--
that start activity,
activity compact thing--
can we make that even easier?
So we started the navigation
architecture component.
And we introduced it to you all
in I/O this last year in 2018.
If you have arguments
to something,
how do we make this nice?
So we built a cradle plugin
called safe-args, which,
for every destination
in your graph--
such as this main fragment--
we generate a directions object.
Which has a nice, simple
show profile method,
which gives you a directions
object with type safe arguments
that you define in
your navigation graph.
And then you just
call a navigate.
And that's it.
We'll take care of
all of the fragment
transaction-- all of that
sort of stuff for you.
So this makes it a lot easier.
So rule number one
of testing things
at the destination
level is don't
test the destination level.
it's really the number
one thing with testing
is making things
nice and separate.
And extracting some
of that business logic
out of a destination
and into something you
can test in isolation.
So how can we do this?
So this Monday, we
released Fragment 1.1--
the first alpha.
And with this,
became a new artifact
called fragment testing--
just about six years overdue.
And it's really around being
able to test your Android X
fragments in isolation.
Separate from an activity,
separate from everything else,
but being able to
test and verify that,
that fragment is
doing the right thing.
We have a mockable layer.
One of the things that we found
when building navigation is
that most companies--
once they got to a certain
point and they're like, wow,
we should add some testing.
And they're like, wow, we can't
really test start activities.
So they built their
own navigator,
which just provides a layer
to mock out the start activity
calls.
Well, that layer
is handled for you.
It's called NavController.
We test NavController.
So now what we can
do in our activities
is just mock out
that NavController
and confirm that
yes, you're calling
the right navigate calls.
You can actually do constructor
injection into fragments.
You no longer need to only
have a no args constructor
to use fragments.
You can use a fragment factory
to instantiate your fragments
for you.
We do recommend using
multiple activities.
Not a lot, though.
So what I'd like to say
is you don't actually
need multiple activities.
what you need are
multiple tasks.
I'd really like to end
this with one note.
A lot of you have
existing apps that
have very different
kinds of experiences.
And I'd like to say, do
what's right for your app.
I think single
activity is great.
If I was writing
a new activity, it
would also be single activity.
But I realize that
going to your PM
and being like hey,
let's rip the whole app
apart is sometimes a hard sell.
Some of them don't
like your current app
so maybe you'll actually
get some yeah, OK.
Go for it.
Really depends on
your experience.
If you find yourself
contorting your own experience
and it's not making sense
to you, don't do it.
If something is working--
that's good.
Keep it working.
But if you're finding
you're running into issues,
you're having
inconsistent behavior,
or you want to do things
like shared view models--
maybe that's the time
to think about moving
towards a single
activity structure.